What’s up guys, my name is Colin McNeil for theScore
esports.
Ya know, in CS:GO, there are few things in more
satisfying than a good AWP kill.
Whether it’s a 200 IQ wallbang, a dirty no-scope or a sick flick,  I feel like I could watch
these highlights all day.
So you know what, let's go ahead and do just that with the Top 10 AWP kills in CS:GO.
Coming in at number 10 is Stewie 2k’s epic
3k to force OT in the final map of the ELEAGUE
Boston Major Grand Finals.
(Casting)
There are many different ways an AWP can be
effective, but the difference between average
and amazing plays lies right here, at number
nine as Dupreeh hits an insane 2-man collateral
through the smoke.
(Casting)
Bodyy comes in at number eight on our list as he displays his creative abilities with the now infamous
“Bodyy Wallbang”.
After pulling it off in back to back rounds
against Astralis, Bodyy not only shocked viewers
at home, but also French and American casters
on stream.
(Casting)
But that’s not where it ends, Bodyy went
on to re-create the same kill in another match
versus Mousesports, leaving the crowd chanting
his name.
(Casting)
Number seven goes to Fnatic’s JW who stood up and
asserted his dominance making sure all eyes,
were on him.
In an effort to take B-site with a minute
left on the clock, SK ran into the wrong man,
at the wrong time.
(Casting)
Known as one of the best AWPers to ever play
the game, KennyS is no stranger to highlight
reel plays.
At number six, Kenny puts on an absolute clinic for
the crowd in a 1v3 clutch at Dreamhack London.
(Casting)
One of the only players in CS:GO to serve
as both primary AWPer and in-game leader , Fallen
shows us why he is among the best of the best
in this 2v5 clutch in our No. 5 play.
(Casting)
At number four, Guardian shows us why he is one of
best players to ever pick up the AWP.
With just 19 seconds left on the clock, Guardian
puts on a one-man show as he dances around
pillar, wiping out an onslaught of Mousesports
players coming from
all directions.
(Casting)
Our number three play sees Nifty go on an absolute
tear with three VAC worthy shots killing three
Tyloo players during the second map of the
Boston Major Asia Minor’s grand final.
Oh, and each one of them was a wallbang.
(Casting)
Coming in at number two on our list is S1mple,
who, in a 1v2 against Fnatic with 30 seconds
left, drops down from the heavens to no-scope
both Dennis and Krimz to win the round.
This play was so good that it earned S1mple
a graffiti tag on the map as a tribute to
this unforgettable moment.
(Casting)
Blowing past the competition at number one
on our list is none other than Coldzera’s
legendary jumping AWP.
Recognized as one of the most iconic AWP kills
in the game, Coldzera puts a quick end to
Team Liquid’s B-rush with a 4K that could
only be described as devine.
(Casting)
Ok guys, that was our list. But if you have a god-like AWP kill that you think we missed, don't be afraid to flame us...I mean tell us in the comments section below.